if one day i'm pretty sure one day
there will be a robotics company
by robotics company i mean the primary
source of income is is from robots
that is worth over
1 trillion dollars
what do you think that company will do i
think sell driving cars no
it's interesting because my mind went to
personal robotics robots in the home
it seems like there's much more market
opportunity there
i think it's very difficult to achieve
i mean this this
this might speak to something important
which is i understand self-driving much
better than understanding robotics in
the home so i understand how difficult
it is to actually solve self-driving
to uh to a level not just the actual
computer vision and the control problem
and just the basic problem self-driving
but
creating a product
that would undeniably
be um
that would cost less money like it would
save you a lot of money like orders of
magnitude less money that could replace
uber drivers for example so car sharing
that's autonomous it creates
a similar or better experience in terms
of how quickly you get from a to b or
just whatever the the pleasantness of
the experience
the efficiency of the experience the
value of the experience and at the same
time the car itself costs cheaper
i i think that's very difficult to
achieve i i think there's a lot more
um low-hanging fruit in the home
that that could be i also want to give
you perspective on
like how challenging it would be at home
or like it maybe kind of depends on the
exact problem that you'd be solving okay
if we're speaking about these
robotic arms
and hence
these things they cost tens of thousands
of dollars or maybe 100k
and
you know maybe obviously maybe there
would be economy of scale these things
would be cheaper
but actually for any household to buy
the price would have to go down to maybe
thousand bucks
yeah i personally think
that uh
so self-driving car provides a clear
service
i don't think robots in the home they'll
be a trillion dollar company will just
be all about service
meaning it will not necessarily be about
like a robotic arm that
helps you i don't know
open a bottle
or wash the dishes or
any of that kind of stuff it has to be
able to take care of that whole the
therapist thing you mentioned
i i think that's
of course there's a line between what is
a robot and what is not
like doesn't really need a body but you
know some
ai system was some embodiment i think
so the tricky part when you think
actually what's the difficult part is
um
when the robot has like when there is a
diversity of the environment with which
the robot has to interact that becomes
hard so you know on one spectrum you
have
industrial robots as they are doing over
and over the same thing it is possible
to some extent to prescribe the
movements and with very small amount of
intelligence the the movement can be
repeated millions of times um
there are also you know various pieces
of industrial robots where it becomes
harder and harder like for instance in
case of tesla might be a matter of
putting a a rack inside of a car
and you know because the rack kind of
moves around it's uh it's not that easy
it's not exactly the same every time it
ends up being the case that you need
actually humans to do it
and while you know welding cars together
it's a very repetitive process
and then in case of self-driving itself
the difficulty has to do with the
diversity of the environment but still
the car itself and the problem that you
are solving is
you try to avoid even interacting with
things you are not touching anything
around because touching itself is hard
and then if you would have in the home
uh robot that you know has to touch
things and like if these things they
change the shape if there is a huge
variety of things to be touched then
that's difficult if you are speaking
about the robot which there is you know
head that is smiling in some way with
cameras that it doesn't you know touch
things that's relatively simple
okay so
to both agree and to push back
so you're referring to touch like
soft robotics like the actual touch
but
i would argue that you could formulate
just basic interaction between
uh like non-contact interaction is also
a kind of touch and that might be very
difficult to solve that's the basic this
not disagreement but that's the basic
open question to me
with self-driving cars and disagreement
with elon
which is how much interaction is
required to solve self-driving cars how
much touch is required you said that
in your intuition touch is not required
in my intuition to create a product
that's compelling to use you're going to
have to uh
interact with pedestrians not just avoid
pedestrians but interact with them
when we drive around in major cities
we're constantly threatening everybody's
life with our movements
and that's how they respect us there's a
game theory going on with pedestrians
and
i'm afraid you can't just
formulate autonomous driving as a
collision avoidance problem so i i think
it goes beyond like a collision
avoidance is the first order
approximation
but then at least in case of tesla they
are gathering data from people driving
their cars
and i believe that's an example of
supervised learning data that they can
train their models uh on and they are
doing it
which you know can give a model this
like
another level of
of a behavior that is needed to actually
interact with the real world yeah it's
interesting how much data
is required to achieve that
um
what do you think of the whole tesla
autopilot approach the computer
vision-based approach with multiple
cameras and there's a data engine it's a
multitask multi-headed neural network
and it's this fascinating process of uh
similar to what you're talking about
with the robotics approach
uh which is you know you deploy neural
network and then there's humans that use
it
and then it runs into trouble in a bunch
of places and that stuff is sent back so
like
the deployment discovers a bunch of edge
cases and those edge cases are sent back
for supervised annotation thereby
improving the neural network and that's
deployed again
it goes over and over until
the network becomes really good at the
task of driving becomes safer and safer
what do you think of that kind of
approach to robotics i believe that's
the way to go so in some sense even when
i was speaking about you know collecting
trajectories from humans that's like a
first step and then you deploy the
system and then you have humans revising
the
all the issues and in some sense
like this approach converges to system
that doesn't make mistakes because for
the cases where there are mistakes you
got their data how to fix them and the
system will keep on improving so there's
a very
to me difficult question of how hard
that you know how long that converging
takes how hard it is
uh the other aspect of autonomous
vehicles this probably applies to
certain robotics applications
is society right they put
as as the quality of the system
converges
so one there's a human factors
perspective of psychology of humans
being able to supervise those uh even
with teleoperation those robots and the
other is society willing to accept
robots
currently society is much harsher on
self-driving cars than it is on
human-driven cars in terms of the
expectation of safety so the bar is set
much higher
than for humans and we're so if there's
a death in an autonomous vehicle that's
seen as a much more
um
much more dramatic than a death in a
human-driven vehicle
part of the success of deployment of
robots is figuring out how to make
robots part of society both on the just
the human side on the media journalist
side and also on the policy government
side and that seems to be
maybe you can put that into the
objective function to optimize
but that is that is definitely um
a tricky one and i wonder if that is
actually the trickiest part for
self-driving cars or any system that's
safety critical
it's not the algorithm it's the society
accepting it
yeah i i would say
i believe that
the part of the process of deployment is
actually showing people that the given
things can be trusted yeah and you know
trust is also like a glass that is
actually
really easy to crack at yeah
and uh damage it and
i think that's actually
very common with uh
with innovation that there is some
resistance toward it yeah
and uh it's just a natural progression
so in some sense people will have to
keep on proving that indeed these
systems are worth being used and i would
say
i also found out that
often the best way to convince people
is by letting them experience it yeah
absolutely that's the case for tesla
autopilot for example
that's the case with uh yeah with
basically robots in general it's it's
kind of funny to hear people talk about
robots like
there's a lot of fear
even like legged robots but when they
actually interact with them
there's joy i love interacting with them
and the same with the car
with the robot
if it starts being useful
i think people immediately understand
and if the product is designed well they
fall in love you're right
it's actually even similar when i'm
thinking about copilot the github
co-pilot there was a spectrum of
responses that people had and uh
ultimately
uh
the important piece was to let people
try it out and then many people just
loved it especially like
programmers yeah programmers but like
some of them you know they came with a
fear
yeah but then you try it out and you
think actually that's cool okay and you
know you can try to resist the same way
as you know you could resist moving from
punch cards to let's say
c plus plus or so
and
it's a little bit futile
you